hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play one late night
now this game was released just a few
days ago but apparently it's a very well
made short horror story a short horror
game experience yes
that's exactly what it is so I don't
know anything about it uh there was like
a graphic designer or something a
graphic designer who oh there's a splash
screen okay so yeah ooh there's a
balloon there not sure what that has to
do with anything okay so got all this we
got all this we got all this gah this I
don't care
looks great let's go dumb let's see okay
I see you soon hey sorry but I will be
later than expected not sure when but
I'll call you on my way home okay so
it's some sort of graphic designer he's
trying to talk to his girlfriend who
he's never gonna see ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever again
whoa what the hell whoa close his hand I
was like what the hell was that
oh nice textures hmm who's better made
than I thought
time to check to see if the coffee's
writing okay
sounds good to me oh I guess I was
raising his head head off of his hands
all right so anyway not sure what the
objective is but let's find out okay so
yeah this is actually really impressive
I don't know what engine it's on I would
guess unity but I might actually be
wrong in that one okay so I can interact
with stuff okay so that's my computer
what the hell where's that whatever hang
on okay I can open these two by
left-clicking that Crouch cannot seem to
it sounds like my printers doing some
over there mine an office or something
where am i huh
Roberts office I wonder where he went
one day he's here and suddenly just
vanishes and stop coming to work well
maybe he got tired took a vacation or
was murdered by a diabolical entity okay
what's going on here alright
apparently there is no you can't you can
only go forward or strafe you can't let
go press both buttons and go diagonally
alright so so far everything looks
really good for you know just another
indie game I mean I don't want to say
just another indie game but there's a
bit of a stigma that when people make
short indie horror games they're usually
not high-quality but this is like
exceptionally high well it's coffee I
hope it's a coffee
that's one bubbly ghost and see
programming books all right cool stuff
basically a general office let's just
skip all this I'm not gonna go into each
these ones I'm just gonna go for the
coffee hello coffee hahaha ah yeah
better get back to work with my cup of
coffee I can't seem to move how do i how
do I drink you how do I drink you coffee
oh okay
alright then uh I guess I'll just walk
with it hard today
Hamas Bell Oh what that ah scared me
oh I guess I'm pretty steady with this
coffee
printers doing weird stuff again was
that it's like a pop no no no what is
this I see you ha ha no thank you
I don't want any when did I type this oh
maybe you didn't if the hell okay I
guess I'm going for the drawers now okay
open from the bottom learn from amnesia
hoping from the bottom there's nothing
there
hey what am i doing I'm sitting in my
chair now oh here we go my password I
had a note here somewhere okay use your
name me a password oh come on yeah a
shell on what god oh my I think I broke
I think I broke it
okay me ash lon
okay there we go it worked anyway all
right so what do i do what do I do now
what do I do about this I don't I don't
know hello I don't know how to use Linux
or any sort of programming Oh God
hello world ah open Oh flash uh uh boobs
oh god no that's all my internet
knowledge that's all of it I got no more
oh crap there's something behind me
okay I can't figure that out for the
life of me so I'm gonna figure out if
there's something or anything else in
this office that needs my attention what
the hell oh those aren't legs is just
toilets hello but ghosts are you here
huh no yes
what ghosts look at key Hotel something
in the toilet yeah there's a key in the
toilet
why why Sir picked up Roberts key Oh
interesting
okay so maybe I'm not supposed to know
howdy okay maybe I'm not supposed to
know how to use a Linux box or whatever
that was cuz I typed in a lot of stuff
you didn't see you didn't see what I
typed in I typed in on unbeli I actually
googled Linux box commands and they
didn't work so whatever whatever I got a
key to Robert's office so let's so let's
go in Robert's office it's awfully dark
in Robert's office
I hear her knocks on the door who's her
who's knocks somebody Oh devil in he's
coming closer devil in veil what Robert
sure had some who's he talking about I
don't know he has a Ouija board why do
you I can't okay
there's a Ouija board over there hide
why am i hiding what already to hide
from okay no I'm not hiding that's good
oh there we go there's something that I
should know about in here okay so uh
please anything in there
no can close that I can't Crouch see
okay I hear her knocks on the door she's
coming closer a ghost or the devil in
Vail that's what it was
okay so there's obviously something very
disturbed of me
ish
all right so I don't know hello was that
my phone
hey I'm Oh God hold it hold the phone
hey sorry nothing bad happen get up get
up hide hide
well hide hide hide
okay all right this is good is good it's
good that's good probably nothing bad
about that
I'll try perfectly normal yeah normal
normal don't need to worry about that I
need to worry about that let's turn on
the radio listen to some jams what's up
with my radio I don't know what is up
with your radio you figure yourself out
man
I can't tell you how to do everything
hooking me ash alone okay so what am i
doing I can't do anything doc can't do
anything can't do anything okay still
can't do anything so I need to find out
the password to Robert's computer did
you have opposed to notes somewhere
before I answered the phone and got the
devil incarnate okay close that door so
nothing bad can get me I'm sure
everything will be fine this is password
in here okay good bye one to treat of
like you know your knocks on the door
she's coming closer a ghost huh so
what's the clue here I don't see any
post-it note there's a candle there but
I can't light it can't sit in the chair
no plant all right let's go out into the
office again seems to be awfully
fruitful for me to go out in the office
don't know why though hello unless
there's some particular reason that I
need to hide like oh yeah I definitely
skipped over some of these offices
because I was like let's just go get the
coffee and not explore when we should
explore all right having gone in the
mailroom anything in here that I should
know about new can I get on to that new
can I open these ears hide once again I
do not want to hide damn it I trying to
open the second one my eyes all I don't
think there's anything there I don't
there's no way to cross so there's no
way to open all of them I don't know I
don't know she open these anything in
there no I'm here no can use those no I
have the ability to hide now but I want
to know what the heck I'm hiding from
like what in the whoa oh my me just
don't get some water glug glug
all right so strange things are starting
to happen
oh how startling startling indeed that
was indeed startling oh whoa
balloon yay
I'm sure that means good things good
things are gonna happen
balloons always been happiness did you
know that they're thinking of banning
balloons cuz of a shortage on helium
it does seem kind of frivolous to waste
up an element that is very valuable to
scientific research on party favors but
let's go see this balloon I'm sure this
isn't a trap at all wait what oh okay
balloon hi
okay I was expecting something not that
okay I've made first contact with this
late Oh God that gave me shivers all
over the place oh yeah seriously that
dude laughs that did not hmm
okay so that's a good start okay so now
that I've seen the monster that I'm up
against then I know that I don't need to
know advanced programming so whatever
whatever whatever whatever whatever
let's just go let's just go let's just
go let's go back to my cubicle
I'm sure though glug glug glug glug hey
let me go in the bathroom one last time
maybe there was something else in there
that I missed just want to be I just
want to make sure that I revisit
everything at least once because there
seems to be some okay this is a shadow
on the toilet paper thing okay nothing
in there okay nothing in this toilet Oh
am I using the toilet splosh splish ah
don't worry I peed my pants just a few
minutes ago I'm good to go all right
let's just carry on wait did I check
this room just got a double check double
check everything cuz it's awfully dark
in this room double check everything
anything in here can I hide in here yes
I can no reason I did not mean to hide I
did not IIIi did not whoa whoa whoa hey
whoa hey hey Easter Egg Easter egg come
on
jaimé jaimé jaimé hi mine there we go
aha hey problem okay that was that was
totally not worth it it's trollface okay
pat it no more easter egg okay I found
everything in here let's wander back
slowly to my cubicle as we wait for more
things to happen Gloup Gloup Gloup Gloup
Gloup look
what's that sound
that's the rain Outsiders as something
else and why am i trapped in here ha ha
run run run run fine fine fine fine fine
fine hide hide
Oh God hide hi May oh I can't see
anything
Oh my vision is royally messed up my
video processor can handle this oh I
hear her
I've even closed the door Oh what was
that
am i safe am i safe okay oh I saw a post
it there
those opposed it under there hang on it
was a whoa call check my drawer I can
it's locked and there but there was a
post-it underneath here let me just see
if I can get hide under there again um
come on hide hide me hide right there's
gonna be very frustrating if I can't get
there's something there's something
there I can't quite see it from here
and sucks because I can't quite do
anything unless I can hide on the other
side of the desk somehow let me try that
gimme pardon me yes I can okay so let's
see ah I can't read you what do you say
Michelangelo Michelangelo
okay Michelangelo Michelangelo okay I
can log into his computer now so let's
do this see me Michelangelo
hello oh no how do this ah ah I still
don't know how to do anything about this
fudge poopie oh come on exit exit exit
exit
okay what's the deal it's a no yeah
check my drawer uh-huh
nice no picked up note number one from
Robert good I can get I can get oh oh
now I cannot oh the light is your friend
don't tell me the lights are about to
turn off Oh screw you Robert and now I
have a flashlight
Oh screw you Robert so hard if you're
gonna turn out the lights
Oh screw you no batteries on so boned
don't tell me that I need to go through
the whole office again looking for
batteries I'm okay so alright alright so
now I need to find notes from Robert I
can log into as a computer but I still
don't know it what to do about that I
have nothing don't know okay so some
lady I don't know who decided to die in
an office right is this how the office
ends the show the office probably Pam
dies and starts murders oh haha hi I see
you - you look like a ugly [ __ ] ah
no no no no no no hide hide hide hide
hide hide hide hide
I got fuzzies all over my face yeah
anybody there
anybody everybody doesn't sound like
chase music and it doesn't seem like
sort of chase stuff that I had before
let me go back to my room because that's
where the sounds coming from why is my
face all fuzzy turn off uh oh boy oh boy
oh boy do I need to hide I can't hide in
this room oh yes I can okay I can't okay
like it okay so my face is still kind of
fuzzy but that's okay it's not
inhibiting my ability to be run away
like a little girl so I'm gonna be okay
oh those screens are still huh why why
are you still up screens hello hi yes hi
okay yeah someone turned off the fuzzy
okay good I was about SEC all right so
anyway uh-huh magic vibe magic wipe need
to find some batteries there probably
some in the janitor's closet but I'm
gonna go into each one of these places
just in case more things want to pop up
on screens and startle me look look look
look look
what okay nothing in there nothing in
there nothing in here nothing nothing
nothing nothing nothing it just must be
in the janitor's closet let me go over
there
yeah I'm surprised they're doing a lot
of stuff in such a small area kind of
reminds me a paranormal in a way
actually it reminds me a lot of
paranormal okay so with that chair looks
weird all right batteries batteries
batteries he's got to be batteries
around here somewhere batteries bear
batteries you rush yeah
slam it in there so that they can turn
off the lights I picked up one battery
uh two batteries there we go okay come
on come on come on
what whoa oh oh it's such bull oh oh you
see that did you see did you see that
you see that she ha ah okay all right so
I'm not gonna get into again it took way
too long to get where I was in the first
place
and that's mostly because walks so slow
talk time and then you need to catch
your breath for five minutes okay so
anyway that was a fantastically made in
the or game I wish I could have gotten
into it more but I mean I spent a long
time on doing this and you didn't even
see the part that I cut out just so that
I could get away from all the
programming oh god but anyway if you
guys know or have tried this out for
yourself I recommend links in the
description try it for yourself check it
out give it a fair review I think it's
got a lot of potential to it and it's
really well made like really is I'll be
surprised like if these guys didn't go
to school for game design or something
like this so check it out for yourself
let me know what you think of it let me
know if you got tips for me if you want
me to revisit it
blah blah blah blah blah let me know in
the comments below so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos soon I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye ha
ah